in a conference Hall in Canada a United
Nations deal double send ripples around
the planet almost a third of the land
and sea area will be set aside for
nature by 2030 protection that should
reverse the Steep decline in both the
abundance and variety of life on Earth
it's good for all species including us
humans actually so this is a very
important thing for all of the planet
and all Humanity together the big
challenge is now to make sure that these
don't remain just words on paper but
they really are going to turn into
action going to be turned into action
countries now and really now need to
start implementing those girls and
targets Wildlife populations have
plunged by 70 over the last 50 years
shrinking habitats pollution hunting and
overfishing have all taken their toll
this isn't just about the one million
species threatened with Extinction they
are a symptom of an underlying crisis
that threatens us too trees provide our
oxygen insects pollinate our crops
plants are the source of many of our
drugs nature is our life support
job uncommon in Surrey is one of the few
remaining areas of lowland Heath in the
UK and a vital refuge for wildlife but
nature reserves aren't enough and
conservation groups safe farming which
takes up two-thirds of the country needs
to be far more Wildlife friendly
we want to see what we would call
regenerative agriculture and what that
means is farming with nature so that
you're reducing your inputs from things
like pesticides and nutrient inputs
you're creating buffers in your
landscape to reduce the impacts of
severe weather and create habitat things
like hedgerows are really important on
farms just three percent of England has
proper nature protection according to
Wildlife groups that while the
government has led the global effort for
a 30 Target it won't commit to domestic
legislation
I think key thing that we need to do and
we'll concentrate on now is making sure
that we have an increasing amount of
habitat around the country that's why we
have legislated to bring half a million
more hectares into place but we're proud
of our record as well of supporting
countries around the world so together
this is a global Target we want to reach
and we will hold each other to account
on paper this is an historic deal for
nature but a lot depends on delivery not
just in setting aside land but handing
over money to poorer Nations so they too
have the means to allow Wildlife to
thrive Thomas More Sky News